salut à toi digne membre de la team
mentale au mental au wip menthe à l'eau
alors je m'assieds car oui contrairement
à ce que vous avez vu sur la vidéo
d'hier jeu ce n'était pas un fond vert
je n'ai pas à genoux j'étais juste assis
à même le sol quand j'ai fait la vidéo
de ce dimanche depuis fin août dans les
commentaires vous me demandez comment
apprendre secours plus rapidement et
plus facilement alors on va pas se
mentir ya pas de méthode miracle pour ça
et en plus de ça j'ai déjà donné pas mal
de techniques dont beaucoup de vidéos
depuis le début de l'année le but de la
chaîne et aussi d'être un petit peu
pédagogique du début d'année à la fin de
l'année mais quand vous êtes arrivés
gare était déjà 200 vidéos
alors j'ai pris la décision que
aujourd'hui j'allais vous donner des
astuces en plus et vous faire un petit
espèce de panel de techniques et de
méthodes pour mieux assimiler ces cours
la première astuce c'est de bien écouter
lors du court évidemment ça paraît
logique mais qui le fait vraiment à
chaque fois chercher en permanence à
comprendre
à écouter et à retenir durant le court
plus tôt car noté faire des belles
feuilles des belles pages c'est bien
mais vous pouvez les faire plus tard
chez vous deuxième astuces et de relire
le cours le soir même même si vous avez
passé de matières lannelongue ma mémoire
c'est un petit peu comme une forêt et
quand vous apprenez quelque chose vous
tracer un chemin dans cette forêt et
plus vous allez repasser sur ce chemin
là plus le chemin il va être défini lors
du premier passage il n'est pas encore
très creusé ce chemin là donc si vous y
repasser le soir même
en relisant votre cours vous allez
commencer à la console idéale solidifier
et je tape beaucoup trop fort dans ma
main 3e as tu sais quand vous allez
vouloir travailler secours essayé à
chaque fois de vous faire une petite
fiche c'est pas vraiment une note de
lecture
c'est plus une note qui va vous
permettre de mieux comprendre les choses
c'est en cinq questions
c'est quoi ça sert à quoi comment avec
quoi pourquoi peu importe que ce soit un
cours de math d'un cours de géo un cours
de sciences littéraire technologique peu
importe que c'est pour réussir à
répondre à ces questions vous allez
forcément faire un petit travail de
réflexion et de compréhension ça va vous
obliger à avoir une vision globale du
court est ce que le cerveau comprend le
cerveau le retient le pratiquent ce
cerveau imaginons que cette vidéo était
en cours et ce n'est pas un couvre ça
donnerait c'est quoi une vidéo qui
synthétise plusieurs méthodes pour
apprendre ces cours plus rapidement ça
sert à quoi à s'optimiser à être plus
efficaces comment en ayant une
méthodologie d'apprentissage avec quoi
avec différentes astuces et c'est celle
que je donne tout le long de la vidéo
donc là je parle héros synthétiser et
pourquoi pour être plus efficace par
moins de temps qu'on apprend c'est court
et surtout rentabiliser ce temps là dans
la durée une deux trois quatrièmes
astuces la 4e astuces et de relire ses
cours avant
dormir quand vous avez la matière le
lendemain relisez le court juste avant
de vous endormir le soir dans vos clips
est vraiment relisez le ne cherchez pas
la prendre juste relisez le c'est la
nuit que la mémoire s'organise et fait
tout son travail il ya des techniques
avec lesquels vous serez sûrement plus
ou moins à l'aise pour apprendre
beaucoup plus vite et dans toutes les
vidéos que j'ai pu réaliser sur la
chaîne
il y à des techniques qu'ils sont
vraiment adapté pour ça et je vous mets
un lien des cinq vidéos dans le
descriptif donc la lecture rapide la
lecture rapide permet donc de lire
beaucoup plus vite et d'avoir un
meilleur taux de compréhension
contrairement à l'idée reçue qui dit que
plus on lit lentement et mieux on
comprend ce n'est pas vrai en deux les
mânes map j'en parle souvent d'ailleurs
il ya une vidéo avec vos my maps qui va
bientôt sortir je pense la sphère en fin
de semaine prochaine si vous voulez
envoyer un magma pour regarder sur la
fanpage de facebook là où tout le monde
a posté la sienne vous mettez la vôtre
et je m'en servir aussi pour la vidéo si
vous pouvez même faire votre prise de
notes en my maps directement c'est
excellent les flash cards j'ai pas fait
de vidéo sur les flash cards parce que
je pense que tout le monde connaît si
vous souhaitez que je fasse une vidéo là
dessus sur ce système là vous me dites
dans les commentaires cartes la
concentration la capacité de se mettre
en concentration avant un début de
kourou avant des révisions la vidéo je
le fais très récemment celle ci 5 à
prendre n'importe quel texte j'avais
fait une vidéo là dessus en début
d'année je vous la remet également
elle permet d'assimiler n'importe quel
texte la méthode a l'air plus longue et
plus compliqué c'est pas vrai c'est
juste un changement d'habitude ça vous
paraîtra plus long pour la première fois
le premier apprentissage mais vous aurez
pu aller revenus et enfin toutes les
astuces et masterclass que vous trouvez
dans la playlist de la mémoire peut
sûrement vous aider à mieux apprendre et
plus rapide j'espère que cette vidéo qui
contient des nouvelles astuces et un
récap de tout ce qui a été fait va vous
servir avoir une vision globale des
outils que vous pouvez prendre vous
pourrez encore plus efficace merci
d'avoir regardé cette vidéo si vous
l'avez trouvé utile d'une manière ou
d'une autre n'hésitez pas à le faire
savoir en laissant un petit pouce en
l'air pensez également à vous abonner
avant de partir si ce n'est pas déjà
fait évidemment et rendez vous demain à
17h châu